curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video
i want to start today by talking about
texas texas is a state that for so many
years we keep hearing
this is the year that texas might change
this is the year that due to demographic
shifts it might no longer be a red state
this is the year a democratic candidate
might win the presidential election in
2020 it was
theorized that maybe joe biden could it
didn't ultimately happen and we've been
talking more and more about texas
including yesterday on the bonus show
which i hope i mean the bonus show at
this point award winning and world
famous if you're not getting the bonus
show what are we doing folks yesterday
on the bonus show i told you
i'm very happy to hear that democrat
beto o'rourke is looking very strongly
as the kids say these days at running
for governor in texas in 2022 against
the incumbent republican governor greg
abbott greg abbott is horrible i mean
really just a horrible person and has
been an absolute disaster for texas
and i'm just as thrilled to tell you
today
that greg abbott's approval rating is
continuing to collapse and crater
and decline as it should
based on what he has done as governor of
texas
and this could shape up to be a major
win for democrats in next year's midterm
so let's quantify this first and then
we'll we'll talk more qualitatively what
are the numbers in texas well greg
abbott's job approval is now down to
just 45 this is a republican governor
in a republican state that increasingly
has purple elements to it for sure
54 of texans say the state is going in
the wrong direction before covid
abbott's approval was 59
59
it's now 45 that's a decline of 14
percentage points
look at how much of a disaster
abbott's ideology and leadership have
been for texas uncovered
he's been on the side of the virus quite
frankly he's been on the side of
opposing ever really closing much of
anything
his lieutenant governor dan patrick
famously went on tv in like um was it
may of 2020 it was very early june maybe
and said we've got to keep things open
folks and grandma's willing to sacrifice
herself for the good of the economy by
which he meant of course the stock
market um the abbott administration has
been on the side of opposing masking
requirements and making them more
difficult to pass the abbott
administration has been opposing
vaccination requirements and or making
them more difficult to put in place and
texas deaths
are spiking pretty badly
this has been one of the worst run
states on covid period
under the vague and almost meaningless
and satirical at this point heading of
freedom and liberty so that's covid
total disaster
but then look at energy
they love to brag in texas republicans
do about we've got this big bad
independent electrical grid we're not
linked to any other states including any
blue states we do our own thing we do
our own generation and bubba we don't
need anybody else
and thanks to that very system last
winter texas experience major blackouts
they tried to blame it on frozen wind
farms and of course we debunked that
total and complete humiliation for their
liberty minded electrical grid this past
summer due to the heat
tech i mean this summer what i mean is a
couple months ago
texas was going in and just adjusting
people's thermostats to try to reduce
electrical demand now to be clear the
customers that had that happen they did
opt into that
but it's not common that it actually has
to be done by the electrical company
just one disaster after another and as i
said yesterday i'm very excited about
beto o'rourke challenging greg abbott
this is building my belief even more
that the 2022 midterms could be some of
not only the most interesting from an
observer standpoint but some of the most
consequential midterms in a long time
abbott's approval rating should be
collapsing he and his administration
have caused unnecessary suffering and
needless death and now in 14 months greg
abbott could be held accountable for it
there are going to be important races in
these midterms at every single level now
of course every member of the house is
up for re-election as they are every two
years
one-third of senators maybe in your
state
one-third are up for re-election many
governors are up for re-election or we
may even have open seats uh as far as
governors are concerned and then of
course state senate
state house they're going to keep trying
to take over school boards we're going
to talk about school boards a little bit
later on in today's program really a ton
that is going to be on the ballot and in
a sense it's a referendum on trumpism as
well we've talked about why uh if the
trump acolytes all get re-elected or
most of them do or trump endorse
candidates win it will
further
the uh grasp that trumpism has on the
republican party it will likely
encourage trump to run in 2012 2024 if
the opposite happens it may dissuade
trump from running in 24 it may push the
republican party away from trumpism so
we will see now to go back to greg
abbott momentarily
he's been a huge disaster
he's failed everywhere
and yet
he and they republicans may still run in
texas on
democrats are going to take your guns if
they win
and that actually could be enough to win
in texas they could do that and they
could end up winning if we don't take
this seriously but we're going to have
plenty of time to talk about better or
works candidacy as we get closer to the
midterms i keep telling people on the
bonus show in my discussions with
youtube with our youtube rep it seems
more and more
like the expectation is the midterm
build is going to start earlier often
doesn't start until late april into may
fully expecting by late february
mid-march at the latest late march these
midterms are going to get going the
texas race with beto o'rourke believed
to be set to challenge greg abbott
going to be a big part of that and we're
going to be covering that as well we
also will be covering what is this
building and continued
sort of civil war within the republican
party and that's what i want to talk
about next
there is a new report that former
president donald trump is now actively
working to remove mitch mcconnell as the
leader of republicans in the senate now
what's funny is trump's worth that work
ethic
we we learned with him as president is a
disaster so the fact that trump believes
is believed to be actively working
towards something may not really mean
very much but regardless let's talk
about uh what is being reported at this
point in time business insider reporting
trump is actively working
to oust mcconnell
as the senate republican leader now
remember because republicans don't
currently control the senate mitch is
the senate minority leader rather than
the senate majority leader okay just a
just a point of clarification to ensure
that we have clarity this evening
former president donald trump
has spoken recently with republican
senators and political allies about
ousting minority leader mitch mcconnell
from leadership and is gauging whether
there's any interest among lawmakers for
a possible challenge according to the
wall street journal there appears to be
little support for such a drastic move
according to the report but trump's
actions could potentially morph into a
larger issue for the party especially as
the kentucky republican hopes to regain
the senate majority in the 2022 midterm
elections and the former president
continues to float a potential 2024 bid
so you have these two factors coming
together you have republicans want the
senate back in 22
and there doesn't seem to be much of an
appetite from the base to remove mitch
mcconnell as the leader on the other
hand donald trump is thinking about a
run in 2024
mitch mcconnell at least over the last
nine months has not been a particularly
big friend to trumpism and you have this
conflict which way are they more likely
to go
um while trump and mcconnell worked
together
to fill scores of federal court
vacancies and with conservative jurists
along with passing the tax cuts and jobs
act and other republican priorities
trump's intransigence in accepting his
election loss to now president joe biden
and the january sixth capital riot
deeply strained the relationship between
the two men that's sort of an
understatement in the sense that at
every rally trump has done recently
which we've covered just about all of
them
he actively goes after mitch mcconnell
and so-called rhinos and talks about how
bad actually mitch mcconnell has been
rarely let me put a different way i
don't want to say rarely
i don't remember even a single instance
of a current or former republican
president being this hostile
to a republican senate leader
it's not even that it's rare i just
don't remember any other instance i'm
glad to be reminded of one if you're
aware of one
um the article goes on to say after
trump's second senate impeachment trial
for incitement of insurrection for his
role in the riot mcconnell declined to
find the president guilty
but sharply rebuked him on the senate
floor later mcconnell said he would
support trump in 24 if he were the
nominee but trump has not forgiven the
minority leader for his speech
trump has continued to needle mcconnell
in the press he recently took the
minority leader to task for backing the
1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure package that passed the
senate last month calling the
legislation a disgrace
trump saying quote if mitch mcconnell
was smart which we've seen no evidence
of he would use the debt ceiling card to
negotiate a good infrastructure package
we'll actually talk a little bit about
that on the bonus show today as well so
let's see how the bass reacts i welcome
the self-cannibalization or i guess you
don't have to say it's just the
cannibalization
self-cannibalism well you guys know what
i mean i welcome the republican party
eating itself
so far
the base which supports trump has
certainly
cheered on trump's attacks on other
republicans at least his rallies at
rallies but a lot of those rally goers
are confused by what's going on they
don't know you know left is down
whatever they don't know what's going on
they would probably cheer whatever trump
says it's it's not clear they actually
are
understanding what they're doing
uh but
we could see a change in the interest of
the trumpian
uh wing of the republican party
in supporting trump's attacks on the
establishment republican party
uh in particular if trumpism doesn't do
well in the midterms in terms of ousting
mcconnell mcconnell was just re-elected
in 2020 he's there until 2026.
i have a difficult time thinking that
republicans will really turn on him
as long as something completely insane
isn't found in mcconnell's closet i i
actually am hoping trump succeeds at
creating chaos and hostility against
mcconnell in a more serious way among
the republican establishment i just
don't think he can do that much
but anything he's able to do is likely
to fracture the republican party and
that's a really great thing it would be
terrible for republicans in the upcoming
midterms to be fighting each other as
much as they're fighting democrats it
would be great for democrats for
republicans to be fighting each other
it's just really not clear at this point
to what degree donald trump can get
republicans angry against other
republicans in a way that will actually
have electoral consequences i just don't
know the answer to that now this
saturday trump is doing a rally in uh
i believe it's in georgia
my plan is to cover it technology
permitting and schedule permitting uh we
will see to what degree trump attacks
republicans and the location of this
rally in georgia is actually very
important donald donald trump we talked
yesterday
just released this letter uh written to
officials in georgia all republicans
remember demanding that the rightful
winner of the 2020 presidential election
in georgia be announced trump means
himself by by saying that um and there's
a very good chance in particular with
saturday's rally being in georgia that
trump will go really hard
against the republicans in that state
it'll be interesting particularly in
light of the mitch mcconnell plan that
trump is developing and you know plan
may be a bit of a generous term it'll be
interesting to see to what degree the
crowd cheers trump's attacks on
republicans so that's saturday in the
meantime
tell me this find me on twitter at
deepakman and tell me this
do you really think republicans might
turn on mitch mcconnell i have a very
difficult time seeing it let me know
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on curiositystream i'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library i just finished watching
becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com slash pacman25
the link is underneath this video
i want to talk about a story in which a
daughter whose dad recently died of
kovid
went on cnn
and at least partially blamed fox news
propagandist tucker carlson for his role
in her dad's coveted death uh her dad
falling for misinformation including the
misinformation he consumed from tucker
carlson and there's sort of like
three stories here one is to what degree
if any
does tucker or do other media people
uh bear responsibility for these deaths
number two is there something that feels
a little bit off or exploitative about
these types of interviews with the
surviving family members and then number
three something a bunch of people
emailed me about which is could there
ever be like a legal responsibility
for someone in the media
um as a result of people that die thanks
to having followed or fallen for that
misinformation so to set the stage just
briefly
this article outlines what happened here
daughter blames tucker carlson's
misinformation for playing a role in
dad's coveted death the 45 year old
father of two
had no underlying health conditions a
washington woman whose father died of
the coronavirus said he was hesitant to
get vaccinated because of misinformation
he heard in right-wing media and
specifically cited fox news host tucker
carlson katie lane said her father 45
year old boeing designer patrick lane
wasn't on the far right politically
we'll get to that when asked what
specifically made her father refuse the
shot the 20 year old cited tucker
carlson
um
katie said her father was waiting for
full fda approval before getting the
shot and this is interesting but by the
time that happened he was already sick
one of his last comments was he wished
he had been vaccinated and there have
been many many people saying i'm just
waiting for that full approval that full
approval has come and gone and many
still not interested in getting
vaccinated for patrick lane it was too
late he was too he was already sick he
couldn't get vaccinated let's listen to
some of the interview and then discuss
why was he so hesitant to get vaccinated
katie
uh
there there's multiple reasons i think
uh one of which was
some of the media that he ingested he
wasn't by any means far right he was
right in the middle and he consumed
media from both sides
and just some of the misinformation on
one of those sides
made him hesitant so he was going to
wait for fda approval but
by the time that pfizer had been
approved it was already too late
weiser got the full fda approval and
your father was already sick
evan
talk to me
about
your final goodbye to your father did
you have a chance
to spend any real time with him so this
is the part that to me is starting to
feel a little bit exploitative i've seen
a bunch of interviews like this and and
there's a disaster porn aspect to it
i'm not feeling fully comfortable with
it including the desire to figure out
what were the last words and you'll see
that at a point soon
john berman actually asks were those his
last words and i think it's it's the
daughter says well those were his last
words to my stepmom or something like
that but there's there's something
that's starting to almost get like
salacious about these interviews and i
don't know that i'm loving it
not really i was already
staying at another house and he was just
coming by to pick something up and
he didn't even
want to get too close because he was too
worried about getting me sick so i
didn't even get to hug him before he
left and then
before i knew he was gone
you guys are vaccinated now evan you
know what what was the message
ultimately
that your father wanted to spread about
vaccines
he wasn't
anti-vaccine he was just hesitant and
i
now that you know pfizer's been fda
approved i don't think he would have
anything wrong with telling people to
get that vaccine he uh his final words
to my stepmom on a facetime call was
that
he wishes he wished that he was
vaccinated
those were his final words
uh to my stepmom uh the last call that
she had with him he said that
he wished that he was vaccinated
so like
what are people with me does this feel
somewhat exploitative like i i mean
if maybe if the point is just convince
people to get vaccinated maybe this is
effective i i just don't know i'm not
sure
and katie you said from
one media source in particular he was
getting misinformed or he was getting
information that led him to be hesitant
on vaccines who i mean who was he
listening to
uh he he watched some tucker carlson
videos on youtube
uh
and some of those videos involved
some misinformation about vaccines and i
believe that that played a role
evan what do you want people to remember
so oh where did where to even start
right um i got an email asking more or
less about legal liability like if you
can demonstrate that this guy wasn't
vaccinated because of tucker carlson
could there be legal liability no
absolutely not i mean you even if in
theory so let's see where there's
multiple reasons as to why not first of
all
how do you
you'd have to demonstrate that number
one were it not only for tucker carlson
this man would have been vaccinated
the vaccine is not 100
effective at preventing death it's very
effective at preventing death but not
100 100 so you could not even prove that
had this particular person been
vaccinated
they would not have died but moreover
you know fox news has already argued
legally
that tucker carlson's show is
entertainment
uh that no reasonable person would would
interpret what tucker says as fact that
it's performative that it's
entertainment and also there are so many
instances and so many media outlets
where disinformation is being spread
whether it's called entertainment or
news
there's no there's not going to be it
would never succeed to try to hold
tucker carlson legally liable for this
so
i guess the questions are
given that it's undeniable that the
misinformation does play a role in
people not getting vaccinated
what could be done what should be done
from a legal standpoint if anything or
is it just a matter of this is just
speech and certainly platforms can
regulate it if they want facebook can
say
we will police disinformation content
about vaccines
but that's not a legal issue it's not
illegal it's just facebook says well
we're not going to allow it on our
platform which is their right to do
and then lastly
how are people feeling about these types
of segments in general the the what were
the last words and and this type of
thing
is there an exploitative aspect to it
is is there an exploitative aspect
that's acceptable if the goal is to
convince people to get vaccinated
let me know what you think
this next story is part tragedy and it's
part comedy of errors
another republican official has sadly
died of covid that's the tragic part
when people die it's a tragedy this time
it's the bookkeeper
for the hillsborough county florida
republican party okay his name was greg
prentiss he was 61 years old he was the
accountant for the hillsborough county
gop
he built and maintained maintained the
local republican party's campaign
finance software last year he was the
guy filing the monthly reports to the
fec the federal elections commission
he also was a big anti-vaxx guy greg
prentice fear-mongered against vaccines
fear-mongered against masks was totally
against other pandemic health guidelines
he attacked dr fauci posting on facebook
that america needs to quote end faucism
well he died
and now nobody else has the login or the
password for the accounts needed
to file these reports with the fec or
any idea how to use them the
hillsborough county republican party is
now
in quite a pickle i guess we would say
they put out a statement saying quote as
a political party committee we file our
fec reports on a monthly basis
for several years we've been submitting
the reports electronically and for over
a year we've done this with software
developed by one of our members greg
prentiss gregg's software converted data
from quickbooks to supply the
information needed by the fec
unfortunately greg passed away suddenly
from kovid on september 11th greg did
not share the software and instructions
for its use with our officers we will
have to enter august data manually and
according to the information we've
received from our fec analyst we may
likely have to re-enter the data from
our first seven months of 2021. we will
be struggling to get all of this entered
in the proper format by our deadline on
september 20
but we will try to do so with our best
effort
this is another bizarre example of covid
crippling the republican party but quite
different than what we've become used to
now as another little note uh greg
prentice's death has also opened up a
whole
deluge of conspiracy theories from other
local republican party officials one who
called kovid a quote medically
engineered virus and suggested without
any evidence that greg prentice's death
was actually a result of wrongdoing by
the hospital where he was being treated
rather than by covet itself in other
words it it guy rants against vaccines
and against masks for over a year
catches covid and ends up in the
hospital
dies
and the conspiracy is it wasn't coveted
that killed him
it was improper it was malpractice
essentially
by the doctors not covid itself
and and this is again as we've talked
about before
this is indefeasible the the classic
example is i come to you and i say sir
there's an invisible elephant in the
room with us right now
and you say okay well it might be
invisible
but it still
has weight
so let's put a scale down and we'll know
if there's an invisible elephant here
because the elephant will step on the
scale and then i say well no not only is
it invisible it's also a weightless
invisible elephant i say okay all right
fair you know what
it must still move the air around it so
let's put down a bunch of baby powder
and as the invisible weightless elephant
moves around because it has volume it
will still displace the baby powder and
then i say no no no it's invisible and
weightless and it has no volume and it
doesn't imp
at a certain point
you can't defeat any argument that is
based on this kind of framework he
didn't really die of covid he died from
being mistreated at the hospital
what we'd really
uh love to be able to see
is these people lose
because they don't offer policy uh that
makes any sense
and because they run terrible elections
not
because they're unvaccinated and dying
of covet that would be my preference and
imagine by the way if the situation was
reversed
and you had democrats saying hey you
know what we had one person with the
password to the accounting software
they died so now we're gonna be late on
filing with the fec the maga people or
the q people or whoever they would be
saying
the clintons had him killed the clintons
had him killed because the fec documents
were going to expose that they were
fill in the blanks absconding with money
whatever the embezzling whatever the
case may be
crazy situation you got to share that
username and password we'll have more
coverage of this and similar stories on
our instagram find us on instagram at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today i'm going to be speaking with
spencer headworth who's assistant
professor of sociology at purdue
university affiliated scholar of the
american bar foundation on also author
of the book policing welfare punitive
adversarialism
in public assistance
it's great to have you on i really
appreciate your time
thanks for having me it's good to be
here so um you know i think maybe to get
us into this conversation oftentimes in
popular culture
people will point to
the ronald reagan stories about welfare
queens as really raising the level of
suspicion around welfare programs and
and so-called free riders
how far back can we trace that suspicion
about people receiving benefits they
don't really deserve in this type of
idea
sure so it goes back about as far as
organized poverty relief programs go
back so you can look at english poor law
in the 15th century in the 1400s in
england and in those very early versions
of assistance programs there were
provisions for
you know inspectors basically to check
up on people and see if they were
drinking or gambling with the assistance
that they were getting uh from the state
and in the united states
again it tracks back to the kind of
earliest versions of public assistance
programs that were out there
and
in the 20th century when we get
food stamps to predecessor to snap
uh the
kind of earliest food stamp uh
provisions included checking on people
to see if they were violating rules um
and there's it's a long history that's
intertwined there really is is almost no
uh historical period where welfare
programs did not include some kind of
suspicion checking evaluation types of
mechanisms
that said it certainly does ramp up uh
in the reagan administration in the
united states as a politically and
popularly salient issue and a period
when we get uh several key legal changes
so if a um certain program
has requirements in order to qualify
it seems intuitive that you would have
some mechanism for policing that and
ensuring that the people that are
getting the benefits actually qualify
now
in in some theoretical sense
if
one eliminated all of this uh
bureaucracy for policing
there's some cost to that bureaucracy in
theory it might actually
in the net cost less not to worry about
the so-called free riders and eliminate
the cost of the bureaucracy has that
been studied with any particular
programs
uh so economists have you know looked
into this at least to some degree with
uh regard to like a ubi type of system
right a universal basic income
uh the idea of you know taking a
means-tested program like snap like uh
tanf that we have now and completely
eliminating
the
expenses associated with the policing
mechanisms it's really hard to tell uh
you can do some things some very you
know basic you know back of the napkin
how much are we recovering per
investigation type of math but that does
not take account for whatever deterrent
effect the existence of fraud
investigation has um the
kind of broader symbolic uh components
of the system that have an influence on
people's behavior um which there is some
influence but it's really hard to
determine how it's uh you know the kind
of counterfactual where we don't have
these programs we don't have data really
right um so
it's tough to say and for the book i
uh the primary data are interviews with
people who work in fraud investigation
investigators and data analysts and
managers of these units and so forth and
they you know
perhaps unsurprisingly given it's their
job but they think that that deterrent
effect which is hard to measure
is is really substantial so it's hard to
say
in uh in in policing by law enforcement
we have many examples of how
a law or a statute can just kind of be
written
agnostically on paper but can be applied
in discriminatory ways or selectively
can you talk a little bit about when it
comes to policing of welfare programs
does the same thing apply and if so how
do we see kind of the discriminate
discriminative application of some of
these programs or of policing mechanisms
rather
so there are ways uh that these programs
uh the way some of the ways that these
programs function
do have some implications i think for
inequities in who's investigated who's
you know potentially charged with
welfare fraud who has these charges
substantiated against them um you know i
will note that all the or nearly all of
the people that i spoke to were adamant
that they do not discriminate on the
basis of
race know have no
feelings about that one way or the other
uh you know one of the basic facts here
is that they mostly investigate women
because women are disproportionately
participants in the program right so
there's that uh there's that difference
i guess the question there would be are
they investigated at a greater rate than
their level of participation
uh they they don't keep statistics on
the characteristics of the people that
they investigate least they told me that
they don't so i can't say that for sure
i can say that
for example being
a person with children as opposed to a
person without children
has at least some effect on increasing
your likelihood of becoming the subject
of a serious investigation
so
the
one of the basic mechanisms here is the
they're trying to figure out which cases
are most promising so they have more
potential investigations than they can
pursue so they choose which ones to go
after right one of the main things that
they're looking for
is a higher dollar value so if you're
the head of a household with children
you're probably getting a higher dollar
value in benefits than if you're not so
that's an example of a just kind of a
mathematical risk factor another
thing that's going on here is
the cases that are most promising to
investigate are cases with more
evidentiary availability right so if you
can get more information about a person
you're more likely to spend more time on
that investigation to make it a priority
because you can get more access to
evidence that you can use to
substantiate your charges so that means
if you are you know quote-unquote on
paper uh in various ways already with
government agencies whether that be
criminal justice agencies agencies of
the welfare state whatever it is if you
have kids in school
all of these are potential sources of
information that welfare fraud
investigators can draw upon to figure
out how much money you make who lives in
your house these kinds of things
so being more
recorded by the state has this sort of
implication of also making you
potentially more interesting as someone
to investigate because this evidence is
out there in ways it might not be for
someone who's less recorded with the
state
when we talk about fraud um
people oftentimes the application
processes for these programs are not
particularly simple
um and there's it seems to me at least
an intent a big difference between fraud
and errors made during the application
process can you talk a little bit about
whether mistakes and errors or
information that has since changed are
are considered fraud under this general
umbrella
um so i mean first i would flag though
the person whose research is probably
the best on this is karen gustafson who
wrote a book called cheating welfare
that's one of the inspirations for this
book that came out a few years ago
with nyu press and you know she focuses
on clients um and so she she delves
pretty deeply into this question of
intent and the construction of intent
and when is a mistake just a mistake um
one thing that i can say for sure from
my
evidence and comparing it with previous
work like currents that looks at the uh
the client side
is that the investigators are much more
likely to see things as intentional and
present them as intentional than our
clients right um and that is in part due
to the
structural factors pertaining here so
uh they are the individual investigators
and the broader units of which they are
parts are incentivized to
get intentional
program violation charges intentional
fraud charges those are the sort of most
rewarding for them professionally they
also garner
financial rewards for the state from the
federal government when you can
substantiate these types of charges so
uh there are things that i think are
borderline um that get constructed as
intentional and i mean the broad
the you know the sort of baseline
understanding here is that if you
provide a piece of information to the
agency
uh and sign your application form saying
that everything that you've sworn to
here is accurate and up to date and then
later they find evidence whether it's
from the department of labor the
department of motor vehicles or a
privately maintained database of some
kind wherever they get it
if they find that evidence that
contradicts
whatever you put on your signed
statement
that is generally considered probative
proof of
intentional fraud
and what is the process for adjudicating
something like that
so in 1976 the u.s supreme court ruled
in
goldberg versus kelly that welfare
benefits are a form of property
and that therefore
participants in the program are entitled
to
some version of due process before
benefits can be terminated
so the way that that works when you're
accused of an intentional program
violation is
in a setting that's called an
administrative hearing
uh administrative qualification hearing
perhaps that is overseen by an
administrative hearing officer that is
the equivalent of a judge
and that's where the client gets an
opportunity to come in and
potentially argue against whatever
allegations are being made present their
own evidence if they have evidence that
contradicts the evidence
that the welfare fraud investigator
gathered
and then the administrative hearing
officer makes a determination of whether
the state has met their
burden of proof in establishing you know
clearing convincing evidence of an
intentional program violation so that's
one of the things that welfare fraud
investigators have to learn how to
navigate and negotiate is
how to work in these settings getting to
know the particular hearing officers and
what kind of standards they have and
it's you know one sort of advantage that
a
fraud investigator has over a client is
they're more familiar with the setting
right they potentially know the hearing
officer they've been there before they
know
you know ms jones likes this kind of
evidence mr smith doesn't like this kind
of evidence right you know they're more
inclined to do this or that
um so that's the that's the setting
where these things are adjudicated and
uh one of the things that fraud
investigators learn is how to navigate
and negotiate in those spaces
one of the um things i wanted to talk a
little bit about is
just other systems in other countries
that may overall be more efficient and
one could argue you know part of it
depends on your perspective but one
could argue that there's lots of
inefficiencies in in these systems one
could argue that the means testing
itself is an inefficiency one could
argue that the methods for policing are
inefficient
there's a lot of different approaches to
that but
in terms of benefits and cost efficiency
overall
what should we be aspiring to what sort
of examples in other countries are
particularly well run
so i'm not an expert on international
welfare states but i will say that there
is i think a very strong case to be made
for
a universal basic income type of system
where you remove
all of this administrative overhead all
of this bureaucratic red tape and um
create a much smoother flowing system
without all of these hurdles and
barriers and all of the associated costs
and the you know expenses uh and so
people who are
uh experts in this area at least uh to
the extent that i've read them you know
generally
[Music]
associate a system like ours that
focuses on means testing
uh with the
almost inherent or uh inescapable
circumstance of rule enforcement being a
big part of it right and this
process of determining who's in and
who's out being
a costly endeavor so in a system where
you can eliminate those
administrative expenses you're saving
that money so i think that there's a
definitely a good case to be made for
more of a uh
universal system i mean something like
we have now in the united states but
just based on age right for social
security benefits and medicare benefits
in such a system
when both when it comes to ubi and
so-called free college
there's the criticism that you're also
giving stuff to the very very rich now
they're very very rich statistically are
a small percentage of of the economy by
by sort of definition is that something
we should worry about or not
well i mean i won't tell people what to
worry about or what to not worry about
but there
i mean there is an inherent logic to a
means-tested system right it makes a lot
of sense i think in an abstract world or
just you know on paper that people in
need should be the people that receive
things but it just gets very complicated
when you come down to the process okay
what is need right how are we gonna
calculate that that's contentious in and
of itself
and then yeah these these administrative
costs i think
um they're often not visible uh publicly
right or not uh really prominent in the
popular imagination and again there is
this inherent logic to
targeting
aid to needy people uh but where the
rubber hits the road it's a lot more
complicated than just
see who's needy give it to them don't
give it to someone who's
not yeah yeah that's for sure that's for
sure uh the book is policing welfare
punitive adversarialism and public
assistance we've been speaking with the
book's author spencer headworth who's
also assistant professor of sociology at
purdue university uh so great having you
on today and really appreciate your time
thanks david it was a pleasure
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show the trouble sort of is continuing
for radical republican congressman
madison cawthorne except it's not really
trouble if there are no consequences and
yet again it seems that's going to be
the case if you're wondering what i'm
talking about i'll explain the entire
thing to you
madison cawthorne
brought a big knife to a school board
meeting that took place at a school in
north carolina
this is against the law okay a new uh
new york magazine reporting last week
madison cothorn the maga congressman
from north carolina attended a school
board meeting in henderson county where
he spoke of course against mask
requirements for students while he was
there an attendee snapped a photo of
what appeared to be a knife stored
underneath his wheelchair by the
following day it was circulating on
social media and the school district
notified authorities and publicly
committed to cooperate with their
investigation in the interest of the
safety of our staff students and members
of the public
bringing a knife onto public school
grounds is a class 1 misdemeanor in
north carolina but the henderson county
sheriff's office announced the
congressman would not be charged
in a statement the sheriff's office said
that the decision took into account the
full circumstances of the incident by
which i guess they mean a republican
congressman did it quote although
unacceptable although unacceptable
occasionally a person inadvertently
possesses a knife
um
politics being what it is writes olivia
nudesy cawthorne's adversaries are not
content to let the issue die with the
ruling from the sheriff's office on
sunday evening american muckrakers a
political action committee that opposes
kawthorne sent a letter to pelosi urging
her to investigate the matter and take
appropriate action the letter includes
further documentation about when and
where cawthorne carries the knife in the
form of a photograph photograph
published in january
the image taken by gabriella demzuk on
the morning of january 6th as cawthorne
made his way to speak to the crowd that
would go on to storm the capital shows
the congressman's fist raised in the air
the letter notes that in the photo below
cowthorne there's an object bearing a
knurled rounded metallic colored end
with a black face a large hole
and an apparent screw head
bearing a strong resemblance to the
microtech sbd
dagger the idea being that this guy is
carrying knives around all the time
so remember that madison cawthorne also
tried to bring a gun in his checked
baggage through tsa security at an
airport now
you might say david why are you saying
tried he said he didn't know it was
there
well
it was there not knowing the location of
your firearm is a negligent act
at best
and um he did try to go through with it
in his in his luggage the idea of well
he didn't know that it was there doesn't
really change that and it was just a big
oopsie no big deal no charges it's cool
everybody won't be charged for the gun
at the airport
won't be charged for the knife at school
so we're definitely seeing a little bit
of a pattern here
and
it is against the law in new york uh in
new york in north carolina it is
unlawful to possess or carry
or concealed any bowie knife
switchblade dirk dagger or other pointed
or sharp edged instrument on school
property
am i
most concerned with this or is this just
a symptom of the bigger issue
the bigger issue is this guy so acutely
so desperately so obviously has no
business being a lawmaker period he has
nothing substantive or valuable to
contribute about mask mandates he went
with the knife to the school board
meeting just to say we shouldn't have
masked mandates he has nothing relevant
to add about school policy or any policy
whatsoever and kawthorne is really
emblematic an example of the worst of
the trumpian republican party along with
marjorie taylor greene
and lauren bobert and a few folks who
have been around a little longer matt
gates louis gomert who's been around
even longer and this is why
i see the 2022 midterms as uniquely
important as far as midterms are
concerned you know we said the 2020
presidential election
was likely
one of if not the most important
presidential elections in a really long
time
that was absolutely true
we don't typically say these are the
most important midterms of our time
i am convinced that the 2022 midterms uh
very well may set the direction of
american politics into 24
26 and 28 at minimum
and if these people get re-elected
assuming they all run for re-election
marjorie taylor green apparently is we
looked at one of her ads yesterday if
hawthorne runs for re-election if bobert
they may have already filed for
re-election i just haven't checked you
you may know more about it than i do at
this point
if they get re-elected it will be a real
signal of the likely trumpian direction
of the republican party and thus much of
the country for the foreseeable future
and you know gun and airport
knife at school it's all very very bad
but most importantly kawthorne is a guy
who
offers nothing in terms of policy they
don't even really hide it i believe it
was an aide to madison cawthorne a few
months ago said
we're not really running a policy shop
we're running i think they called it a
communications office
meaning we're about social media
and memes and images and bullet points
we're not about policy and that's much
of the republican party at this point in
time
there's a this continued rift that is
taking place
within right wing media at this point in
time one element of this is that once
again
supposedly fox news is refusing to air
my pillow ads for mike lindell's company
my pillow we've talked about some
aspects of this before
my pillow is a company
owned by the right winger mike lindell
who's been a guest on this program that
sells pillows and other elements of
sleeping
and they
used to advertise all the time on fox
news
would spend a ton of money advertising
on fox news and presumably get a pretty
good return for it that's why he kept
doing it and fox news has now on
multiple occasions supposedly refused to
air his ads in part it is believed to be
because of the connection between mike
lindell and false claims about the 2020
election there's a new article in salon
which says mike lindell is begging fox
news to start airing his ads again but
the network refuses lindell wants his
ads back on fox but it appears the cable
behemoth isn't ready to take him back
quite yet
the mypillow ceo angrily pulled his
company's advertisements from fox in
july after it ignored the lead-up to a
south dakota cyber symposium and
declined to run an ad for the gathering
but after nearly two months away
the betting magnate appears to finally
be ready to make up with the
conservative network lindell laid out
the situation says he's been trying to
increase
uh to air increasingly watered down
versions of his ads
but that fox news uh doesn't like it
let's go to an interview with mike
lindell this guy really seems off his
rocker but if it is indeed true that fox
is refusing to air them it could signal
an interesting sort of line in the sand
even for fox news as far as ads go let's
listen
because i don't know what swim's gonna
write he's you know he's so far left you
can't even see him and it's so far left
he takes a corner and uh he'll even tell
you that but he's very i like him though
because he's very you know he'll read
back to me at least what my quotes were
so here's the facts um
i you know everybody before the cyber
symposium i put out an ad on fox
telling people about frank speech.com
and the cyber symposium i put that out
to every station in the country fox news
was the only one that denied that ad
that includes your cnns msnbc's abc
cbs's remember i advertise everywhere
with my pillow and this was an ad that
was accepted for free directing people
to the cyber support to watch the cyber
symposium you guys are following this
right that's all it was so when fox
can't when fox would not allow that but
what did not want to be part of this
cancer culture with and had it with them
shame on fox so i canceled all my pillow
ads right now that's interesting that a
private company saying we don't want
your business
is cancel culture as far as mike pillow
is concerned
then we put an ad up two weeks later
everybody
and after the cyber symposium and that
one said hey just go to frank's speech
and you can see great great shows uh and
you can see the if you missed the cyber
symposium well that's not truth in
advertising there are not great shows on
frank's speech that would be a lie
fox was the only one in the country that
denied that ad
then this week um it's early last week i
put another ad i said nothing about the
cyber symposium i said go to
frankspeach.com you can see great shows
we showed some of the shows your diamond
silks all the shows diamond and silk are
now on frank's speech can you imagine
what is happening to this country
and you can get great products from my
pillow and my store
we did that and by the way do you guys
hear what sound like whippets happening
in the background fox said
that they did like the content of the ad
they didn't like us to say
uh oh no the first two ads they said was
about symposium they didn't like the
content of the ads that's why they
wouldn't take them because it said
symposium right
then this third ad fox said they didn't
like the content over at frank's speech
there's either a woodpecker or someone's
huffing whippets teach brandon they
didn't like their show they don't wait
what fox doesn't like my show
i guess not you know but that's no no
you know it gets worse everybody so they
said remember they said one they didn't
like the content of the ad two they
didn't like the content yet three
they didn't like the content of the the
platform the website frank speech the
stuff that was on printspeech.com all
right what a victim huh guys there's
it's just horrible what's going on with
mike pillow um what's interesting about
this the noise in the background is
interesting i will admit but it's it's
very interesting
that there is now this entire wing of
the right the diamond and silk mike
pillow
etc newsmax oan wing
it's too radical for fox news like at
the end of the day fox is right wing
but fox wants to make money they want to
be in rather than out and you even now
have people who watch newsmax saying fox
has become left wing
the mike pillow types the january 6
types and others and newsmax is now
running an ad i'll play it on a live
stream i don't think i'll talk about it
on the podcast but i'll play it on an
upcoming live stream there's newsmax now
has an ad
where in the ad it's audio of trump
saying
fox is uh so so but newsmax is doing
really well at this point in time so a
very strange rift happening within right
wing media but even fox news saying some
of this stuff is even too crazy for us
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is a really important topic i got a
caller who said
is there something about the news
that is bad for one's health
hi david my name is anna um long time
viewer of the show wanted to bring some
female
representation to your voicemail
questions um my question for you is how
do you
protect your mental health while
consuming
so much
just horrible
media yep like
i i feel like my mental health has
suffered just from trying to follow
the world news and follow current events
and i can't imagine what it's like for
somebody that
um
you know does this as their job so i was
wondering how
how you deal with that yeah many people
ask me this so there's two things that
go on one is i'll admit it
you become sort of desensitized to it i
am def there i know when i'm talking to
people not in this business
they will report to me or they will
mention some story in the news
and i can tell i'm not having the
visceral reaction they're having because
i've been desensitized to a lot of the
stuff that's number one but number two
you've got to schedule breaks and uh
when when i'm done producing friday's
show
um until i start getting ready for the
monday show i'm not paying attention to
any news unless there's like some
weekend political event going on that
i'm involved in streaming or whatever
the case may be
and i'm just reading
not politics reading history science
whatever fiction
and doing other things and i think it's
of incredible importance to do that so
the mere fact anna that you're asking
the question
is a very very good sign we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
sign up at joinpackman.com
to get instant access
to the bonus
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video